hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video and I'm sorry for not posting in a
week I know I bleep oh stood the new emo
thing and then I just went like [ __ ]
AWOL for like the rest of the week I
apologize for that there wasn't really
much to cover in terms of news for the
whole week and I was kind of just busy
with a lot of other stuff so to
apologize for that but today's video is
going to be more about newly some stuff
that has happened in the past couple
days that I felt were I guess good
enough for a video because some of these
happen like three days ago but I'm not
just going to dedicate an entire video
to it it would just be too short so I
kind of compiled up a couple things that
have been happening so we're going to
talk about that but before I get into
that you can skip this if you want it's
completely fine but I just want to say
that I thank you to all the new subs
that we've gotten over the past week we
have we got maybe like 60 70 more subs
than we originally had so shout out to
all the new people and today as of as
I'm making this super late at night on
July 18th it is actually my one-year
anniversary if you want to call it an
anniversary since I started YouTube
honestly my goal for my expectation was
just to reach 500 subs but ended up
reaching as of right now about 1593 so
that's three times more than I expected
so thank you all for the great love and
support on this channel I really do
appreciate it as always but anyway guys
enough of a little sob story of my
little history there let's get into this
video so first up there was some
possible defensive meta changes coming
tomorrow and tomorrow being Thursday on
the dev stream director Eric Pope stated
that there's going to be changes in the
dev stream or the defensive meta being
talked about on the dev stream tomorrow
no one knows exactly when it's going to
be or what's going to be in it
so we'll just have to wait and see I'm
assuming they're going to hopefully be
changing something maybe adding chip
damage or at least speculating ideas
getting some from the community and this
probably won't be out till season 3 to
be honest because it is kind of running
low on we're almost done with actually
run 5 to be completely honest I didn't
even
I completely forgot we were almost done
so hopefully this will actually help the
games that have heard it this time next
up Reiter is kind of in a very troubling
spot I guess you can kind of say going
off people's thoughts and post on Reddit
and then my personal opinion I said
Raider is topped here not which is good
because he definitely needed it but I
feel like he might be too good cheer me
out here his moveset can basically be
like be changed into the stunning tab
and even his own can cancel into the
stunning tab which makes for a [ __ ] ton
of mix-ups
and it was definitely needed his
character didn't really have much
besides that and then now he since now
he's basically taught one of the top
tier characters which is but like I said
before a great idea but knowing but
people are saying that Raider Stampede
charge now only takes about a frame of
activation to activate and grab someone
so for example for anybody that doesn't
know Raider has this charge where unlock
taking charger you grab you and then
either throw you with enough distance or
you can wall splat you up against the
wall and get a free light off that hit
but now with this one second of
activation people are now going to be
introduced to Raiders 50/50 basically
what you can do now since you're just
sprinting is that you can sprint up to
them and either stop and guard break
them or continue going and grab them and
throw them off the map into a wall which
can lead to more combos more stamina
join and ultimately lead to that
opponent's death it's not technically
supposed to be in this game because it
is a one frame of activation and it
doesn't even give you enough time to
react and trust me even if you were to
even dodge out of the grab the Raider
would know and immediately guard break
you and then since you're in the middle
of dodging it would basically be you'd
be uncountable so if you were the Raider
you'd get a free hit or whatever and it
would just be the end of that person a
lot of people are saying that they need
to get this fixed I'm 100% on board for
this I'm not a big fan of the Stampede
charge although people are all asking to
have his own attack and not cancel into
a stunning tap anymore like that was a
bad idea
like I said personally I think that was
a perfect idea for Raider now that he's
somewhat top-tier he definitely does
deserve to be up there now with his new
ability and such so anyway we're going
to continue out the next topic though
that also has to do with Raider
so speaking of Raider Slifer made a very
interesting video cipher is a very well
known for on our player in the community
but he came out with a video regarding a
although he noticed so I fir asked the
question if two graders do a stampede
charge at the same exact time who would
win the fight he discovered that the
player who is the host or the person who
has the best connection to the host
basically giving the host advantage
would win that type of duel so if you
and I were to go up against each other
and I'm the host and we do they were
Stampede charge I would get it 100% of
the time guaranteed because I'm the host
this is a prop the ball might not be a
huge problem it could definitely have an
impact on certain scenarios like maybe
your opponent's on super low health you
go for that grab and since he's the host
he goes for it as well but you get
punished like I said because he is the
host and you lose the round this is also
a problem because I don't know if you
guys have been following but before our
hero series tournament has been out
maybe some of you are participating in
it I'm not so sure but it's been going
on and people could possibly be abusing
this glitch so from what I've been
seeing though not many people have been
playing Raider to be fair it's been a
lot of warlords
but this glitch according to cypher also
works a warlord so this is definitely
going to be a huge problem in the higher
tier play you know closer toward the end
of this tournament although if you do
want to see the full four-minute video
I'll link it for you guys as well and
also link is twitch in youtube if you
want to see some action from a high
level player it's very very entertaining
so I do highly recommend you go check
out the video and all this twitch in
YouTube who would definitely be
streaming on Saturday for the tournament
so I recommend you check that out and
then lastly I want to talk about a few
things basically I've been getting a lot
of messages asking for subs whether
they're in the comments or anything like
that about subs asking me if they're
like hey can I message you or hey can i
friend you or want to play a bit -
basically to summarize it all and answer
this question yes you can friend me we
can play a few matches a for honor I'm
always down for that if you have a
question you can always message me or
ask me in the comments I do always
respond and I also been getting a few
other messages saying that I should be
more energetic energetic in my videos
but then some people disagreeing with
them saying that the way I'm now is
perfectly fine so I do want to pass this
off to you guys though should it be more
energetic or stay the way I am
completely up to you
doesn't
they matter to me so I'll change if I
have to it's just once again completely
up to you really doesn't matter to me
but this can be the end of the video
judging by this time it actually went a
lot longer than I expected I thought
this is going to be a short video I do
apologize though if it was a bit too
long for your taste there will be a dev
stream tomorrow that I will cover for
you guys as well like I said defensive
meta possible changes coming that would
be very interesting to see and like the
V if you guys didn't enjoy dislike it if
you didn't subscribe if you're new you
check my most recent video out there if
you haven't seen the emo to being the
top right corner for you to check out
you want to see cypher or any of the
videos that I talked about anything I
talked about there will be links in the
description for you to check out if you
do please and I with that guys I will
see you all later and goodbye